on its opening weekend the Stephen King
adaptation it broke multiple box-office
records when it pulled in a hundred and
twenty three million the biggest ever
September opening for a film horror or
otherwise we can't ignore the impressive
performances from the young cast and of
course the film's terrifying demon clown
let's take a closer look at this group
of fictional misfits and the talented
young actors who brought their
characters to life on the big screen
Jaden Lieber her before landing is
starring a role in it as build n bro
actor Jaden Lieber her started his
acting career with appearances in
commercial spots as a talented
eight-year-old with no professional
training he was soon being cast in films
appearing in Saint Vincent with Bill
Murray playing it cool and aloha before
getting his first starring role in the
2016 science fiction film Midnight
Special
you may also recognize Libra her from
his recurring role as Johnny masters in
the Showtime period drama series masters
of sex Jackson Robert Scott George Eden
bro is Bill's cheerful and innocent
seven-year-old younger brother and well
we all know what happens to Georgie at
only 8 years old Jackson Robert Scott's
budding acting career is just beginning
before appearing as Georgie in it he
also had single episode roles in the
television shows Criminal Minds in 2015
and fear the walking dead in 2017 Sophia
Lillis as the sole female in the losers
Club bev marsh is an obvious target for
the boys adolescent crushes and every
member of the club harbors feelings for
her at one point or another sophia Lilla
started off her acting career with
appearances in several small budget
shorts and feature films including A
Midsummer Night's Dream 37 and the
garden in addition to it you can spot
her this year in a role as the younger
version of the lead character in an
episode of the upcoming HBO series sharp
objects
Jeremy Rae Taylor Ben Hanscom is smart
and extremely talented when it comes to
inventing in engineering but because of
his weight he's frequently targeted by
town bully Henry Bowers and his gang of
cronies before being bullied in its
jeremy ray taylor portrayed a bully
himself in the 2015 superhero movie
ant-man he's also at parts and 42 good
behavior and Alvin and the Chipmunks the
road ship fin wolfhard
Richie Tozier has a tendency to chatter
incessantly and an overwhelming amount
of bravado for his age alongside a
considerable vocabulary of curse words
at his disposal which duly earns him the
nickname trash mouth of all the losers
Club cast Finn wolfhard
is perhaps the most easily recognizable
due to his leading role as Mike wheeler
in the hit Netflix series stranger
things in addition to that role wolfhard
has also appeared in the hundred and
supernatural as well as directing and
starring in the music video for the song
sonora
from spend time palace his next project
will be as the voice of the primary
player character in the upcoming Netflix
animated series Carmen Sandiego Jack
Dylan grazer where Richie is filled with
bravado and appears fearless Eddie seems
terrified of everything due to his
overbearing mother Eddie is a chronic
hypochondriac afraid of his own shadow
and clutching his asthma inhaler like a
holy relic to ward off evil as the
nephew of Hollywood producer Brian
Grazer Jack Dillon grazers talents run
in the family
he made his first appearance in 2014 in
an episode of the greatest event in
television history followed by roles and
comedy bang bang tales of Halloween and
scales mermaids are real following it
grazer can be seen in the CBS comedy
series me myself and I chose and Jacobs
Mike serves as an unofficial historian
for the group helping them connect the
dots between events and dairies past
like the fire at the black spot the
Bradley gang shootout in the mass murder
at the Silver Dollar chosen Jacobs
started his career as a musician in
Atlanta and after moving to California
he landed his first acting role at age
13 in a commercial for hot wheels after
being cast as will Grover in the CBS
police drama series Hawaii five-o he
landed his breakout role as Mike Hanlon
in its with only a single audition
Wyatt Olaf Stan is a bit eccentric and
his Jewish heritage paired with his bird
calling hobby make him a natural target
for Henry Bowers and his gang a
pragmatic and logical boy Stan's sound
reasoning helps Lou
Club on more than one occasion of all
the losers Club cast Wyatt Olaf has the
longest list of acting credits with
roles going back to 2012 he appeared in
television shows like Once Upon a Time
shake it up and scorpion and you might
recognize him from his role as a young
Peter quill in both guardians of the
galaxy films Nicholas Hamilton Henry
Bowers leads a gang of high-school kids
on a campaign of torment aimed at
various members of the losers Club Ben
Hanscom and Mike Hanlon in particular
it's all downhill from there it wasn't
the only Stephen King adaptation to
feature Australian actor Nicholas
Hamilton in 2017 he also appeared as
Lucas Hansen in The Dark Tower and he's
racked up an impressive list of roles in
his short acting career including parts
in the Australian television series
wanted the feature film stranger land
and Captain Fantastic with Viggo
Mortensen Owen Teague Patrick Hawks
Tedder is a psychopathic high schooler
who likes to lock small animals inside
an abandoned refrigerator until they die
which makes him a perfect fit for Henry
Bowers gang oh and Teague made quite a
few appearances in television shows and
films before landing the part of the
psychopathic Patrick you may recognize
him as a young version of Walt Disney in
the 2015 film Walt the for Mickey from
other movies like echoes of war or the
2016 adaptation of another Stephen King
tale cell additionally Teague played the
role of Nolan Rayburn in over 20
episodes of the Netflix original
thriller series bloodline jake sim
although reginald belch Huggins isn't
the brightest crayon in the box his size
strength and loyalty make him a valuable
asset to Henry Bowers crew Jake Sims
acting career really got going in 2010
when he landed a voice role as Tommy
Tibble in the animated series Arthur he
also provided his voice talent to
another animated children's show Stella
and Sam in 2013 on-screen sim has had
roles in several other shows including
the amazing Gale pile and raising
expectations Bill skarsgård at age 27
bill skarsgård is definitely not one of
the kids from it but the terror in
suspense of the movie rests squarely on
its colorful shoulders as penny wise
before taking on the role that Tim Curry
made famous in 1990 Swedish actor Bill
skarsgård appeared in a number
films and television shifts starting
with roles and primarily Swedish
productions like Simple Simon before
transitioning to english-language
feature films and shows like Hemlock
Grove atomic blonde and Allegiant
although he'll presumably be back for
the sequel guards guards next project is
a recurring role in the upcoming Hulu
original series Castle Rock also based
on the works of Stephen King thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Applause]
[Music]